cómo
por favor
sabían que un mexicano pasa un mes
sentado en su coche yendo y viniendo de
su escuela a la casa o del trabajo a la
casa y de regreso
se imaginan un mes en promedio al año
sentado en tu coche cuando lo ponemos
así junto se siente un poco más fuerte
no quién vino hoy en coche particular
algo algo así me imaginaba vez
imaginen el coche para muchos es un
sueño para otros es un significado de
estatus para algunos muchos también
puede ser la extensión de su casa pero
gracias a dios para la mayoría
es una cosa ha funcionado el coche fue
creado para resolver nuestros problemas
de desplazamiento y siempre lo hemos
visto como una solución sin embargo hoy
el coche está causando en algunos
lugares y en algunos momentos más
problemas que soluciones yo soy una
fanática de la data entonces voy a
empezar un poco por ahí en data que
creen que sea este 45 por ciento
alguna idea
nada bueno este 45 por ciento es el
promedio de la vida útil de un coche es
decir el resto del tiempo 95% del tiempo
que tenemos un coche el coche está
estacionado no lo usamos es meramente un
adorno es meramente algo que ocupa
espacio
y aquí la verdad es que siempre felicito
a la industria automotriz por habernos
convencido de no nada más querer un
coche para que nos lleve de un punto a
otro queremos el coche más lujoso el más
equipado y el más link
pero en realidad del coche si pensamos
que solo lo usamos el 5% del tiempo que
lo tenemos es uno de los activos que
posee el ser humano pues más caros y
derrochadores
y regresando a la data tenemos 1.3
millones
algo alguien
[Música]
bueno 1.3 millones es el total de
personas que mueren en un año por
accidentes automovilísticos
si lo pensamos en que más o menos son 16
estadios azteca llenos en partido de no
soy futbolera pero chivas américa
es bastante
tres mil 800 personas más o menos mueren
al día
como les dije soy una fanática de la
data entonces si hacemos un poco de
recolección de estos tres datos que les
acabo de dar que son
alrededor de 35 días sentados en
nuestros coches al año en problemas de
realidad
5 % que es en promedio el uso útil de un
coche
y 1.3 millones de personas muertas en el
año
y eso dejando un poco de lado de los 20
a 30 millones accidentados o
discapacitados también por problemas de
vialidad y accidentes en la en las
calles les pregunto por qué seguimos
manejando
y eso es un poco algo de lo que les voy
a platicar hoy
que el olmos que dijo no hace mucho
tiempo
que
en menos de 20 años poseer un coche será
como poseer hoy un caballo
hoy para que usamos los caballos si hay
gente que todavía los usa para
transportarse pero es el mínimo en
realidad son más como por un uso lúdico
y porque creemos esto hay tres
tendencias que pensamos van a ser claves
si es que esto va a ser realidad y
creemos y los estudios dicen que si el
primero es la urbanización
el segundo es el concepto de poseer
versus tener acceso histórica tenemos
esta cultura los humanos de querer y de
querer tener cosas pero si puedo tener
acceso a ellas sin tenerlas tal vez
puede ser mejor y el tercero es un
cambio en el comportamiento en las
costumbres y en las creencias de las
personas y ese tercero es el más
complicado
entonces hablando de urbanización la
ciudad de mexico es el mejor lugar para
hablar de urbanización
porque porque una megalópolis es
considerada a partir de 10 millones de
habitantes ciudad de méxico tiene el
doble
más o menos en el mundo cada año 3
millones de personas se mueven a las
ciudades
a vivir en estas urbanizaciones entonces
pueden imaginar que nos espera a
nosotros habitantes de las ciudades como
para 2050 en 30 años
si hoy tenemos problemas de
transportación y de movilidad que va a
ser de nosotros en 30 años
70 va a ser de nosotros no el 70 por
ciento de las personas en el mundo se
espera que vivan en ciudades para 2050
esto es demasiado la saturación que va a
suceder en las ciudades
pensamos que va a ser inmanejable si
seguimos comprando y utilizando los
coches como estamos acostumbrados a
hacerlo para 2050 no nos vamos a poder
mover este mes del que les hablo que
pasa un mexicano promedio sentado en su
coche en un año
podría convertirse en mucho más
y aquí es importante mencionar el
segundo punto que es este tema de tener
acceso versus poseer
como les contaba estamos muy
acostumbrados a querer poseer las cosas
y el ejemplo más claro para explicar
este concepto es servían vip
quien no había soñado con una casa de
verano o con una casa de fin de semana
sin embargo era bastante restrictivo y
lo hizo posible para muchas más muchas
más personas y eso mismo va a suceder o
creemos que va a suceder con el tema de
los coches y aquí es donde entra en
juego el famoso coche autónomo que si
bien hoy conocemos el inicio del coche
autónomo este que se estaciona sólo es
un punto hay ciudades en eeuu donde ya
hay 100 por ciento de coches autónomos
sin embargo estos coches siguen siendo
muy parecidos a los que vemos hoy
y nosotros tenemos una visión un poco
más futurista en donde los coches
autónomos van a transportar muchas más
personas de las que vemos hoy en los
coches
y ahí pasamos al tercer punto que es el
más clave y el más complicado
es cambiar el comportamiento de las
personas como la tecnología si bien nos
ha ayudado
y nos ha empoderado a cambiar la
realidad es que esperamos que la
tecnología nos resuelva absolutamente
todo y si la tecnología nos hace las
cosas mucho más eficientes y nos ayuda a
mejorar en muchos aspectos sin embargo
a veces queremos dejar demasiado
responsabilidad en esta cuestión de la
tecnología
pensemos un poco y si lo vemos hoy un
tema muy destructivo está haciendo el
tema de la movilidad
platicando con nuestros amigos de la
secretaría de transportes nos decían que
están empezando a ver un declive en la
solicitud de licencias
en los jóvenes específicamente eso en mi
época era impensable eras como carcelero
contabas los días para cumplir 18 para
ir por tu licencia y hoy hay tantas
opciones alrededor para poderte
movilizar que el coche está cambiando la
industria de la movilidad está haciendo
o pasando por una disrupción más fuerte
que no habíamos visto jamás
entonces por qué es importante cambiar
nuestro comportamiento porque no nada
más podemos esperar a que las próximas
generaciones lo hagan o pensar que la
tecnología va a impactar las próximas
generaciones y yo ya estoy fuera de eso
la realidad es que no nosotros podemos
hacer un cambio hoy e impactar nuestra
propia generación y las siguientes si
pensamos en un niño menor a 5 años los
estudios dicen que ellos ya no van a
manejar ni siquiera les va a interesar
aprender a manejar y cómo les
interesaría así 16 estadios aztecas
mueren cada año por manejar
gastas muchísimo dinero en un coche que
no usas
y por último pasas muchísimo tiempo
sentado en el coche cuando hablo de que
los niños menores de cinco años no van a
manejar normalmente veo la cara de los
hombres de trauma que dice y que le voy
a enseñar a mis hijos no se preocupen
habla algo que les puedan enseñar
y aquí es donde viene muy clave el tema
del cambio de comportamiento
ellos van a tener un día totalmente
distinto al que ustedes viven hoy se van
a movilizar de una manera distinta se
van a desplazar de una manera distinta y
van a ver la movilidad totalmente
distinta como nosotros la vemos hoy se
imaginan por ahí tener una junta de
negocios dentro de un coche autónomo
mientras más camino a otra reunión
o tomar un café con un amigo en lo que
vas camino a tu clase esas son un poco
de las cuestiones que pensamos o vemos
que podrían suceder
pero se requiere de un cambio en
pensamiento muy grande
y el otro tema importante
y le recuerdo que les dije que era
fanática de la nata en hora pico
los coches en méxico tienen una
capacidad como de 1.2 personas cuando en
realidad caben cuatro o hasta cinco eso
significa que tenemos demasiado espacio
desperdiciado ahí
y eso es mi siguiente tema a tratar
hablando de urbanización en las grandes
ciudades los coches ocupan mucho más
espacio que las personas
y es un poco en relación a esto tenemos
una inconsciencia cultural de cómo
utilizamos el coche
si pensamos en una hora pico que en
lugar de traer todos ustedes vienen al
mismo punto y les aseguro
que más o menos de las mismas colonias
si pudiéramos conocer un poco más a las
personas que nos rodean podríamos ser
más organizados y tener mucha más
conciencia de cómo utilizamos el coche
entonces yo sé que de entrada suena raro
y tal vez es la cultura más simple el
tema del aventón pero no lo hacemos
porque es complicado tienes que hacer un
esfuerzo extra y no estamos
acostumbrados a hacerlo pero imagínense
que en lugar de cinco coches venga uno y
eso se multiplique por todos los 35
millones de coches que hay en mexico
si pudiéramos reducir y tener un tercio
de los coches imaginen qué agradable
sería venir hasta la nava del norte esto
iba un poco lejos
y ahí es donde el cambio cultural y de
comportamiento en las personas entra en
juego junto con la tecnología
no podemos dejar la responsabilidad del
cien por cien la tecnología no nos lo va
a resolver al cien por ciento tenemos
nosotros que hacer conciencia del uso
del coche de nuestra educación vial
y nuestra preocupación hacia el futuro
y recordando los tres puntos que les
mencionaba
la urbanización no la vamos a poder
parar como individuos
el poseer versus tener acceso
eso está cambiando muchas industrias
demasiadas diría yo en algunas es muy
positivo en otras todavía no estamos muy
seguros sin embargo esto nos está dando
muchísimas otras posibilidades y acceso
a distintos medios de transporte a que
nuestro desplazamiento sea totalmente
diferente
y tenemos que hacer conciencia cuántas
veces se han encontrado un patín
estorbando lo mueven lo quitan la
mayoría de la gente no lo hace lo dejan
ahí y siguen su camino
y el tercer punto que es el más clave y
el más difícil es el cambio en el
comportamiento de las personas la
tecnología va a jugar un rol muy
importante sin embargo las ciudades del
futuro no pueden depender al 100% de la
tecnología la tecnología necesita
empoderar a las personas para usarla de
manera adecuada y poder en conjunto
resolver nuestros problemas
hoy hablé únicamente del problema de la
movilidad sin embargo hay muchos más
la movilidad el futuro y la tecnología
van a tener que jugar en conjunto y
nosotros como personas vamos a hacer
claves en este cambio
dejemos ser empoderados por la
tecnología cambiemos nuestro
comportamiento y tratemos juntos de
mejorar las ciudades en donde vivimos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]